with reaction south carolina senator
lindsey graham
if the numbers are now as high as they
are
in march what are those numbers going to
be like in may and you just got back
from the border
well you know i was on your show what
three or four weeks ago saying
there's a disaster in the making well
the worst is yet to come
i mean why are so many unaccompanied
minors coming to the our country now
when trump was president the miners
would be sent back to either mexico
or their home country they're all
staying in america
and when i say the worst is yet to come
by the spring
late spring early summer you're going to
have families coming in caravans because
the word is out in central america
they're changing the policy that trump
put in place that if you get to the
border you turn yourself in
you're going to stay in america not
mexico until they reverse that policy
until they go back to the remaining
mexico policy
the worst is yet to come i'm just a
little old talk show host what do i know
lindsay i'm not that smart
but i would think that with 17 million
americans out of work with a pandemic
and now all these high-paying energy
jobs people being laid off and border
wall construction jobs all the pink
slips there
and then what 15 million uh
people are going to get amnesty i don't
know where i went to school i was taught
supply and demand crisscross and dictate
in this case wages
what is this going to do to wages for
american workers
well number one it's going to suppress
wages when
illegal immigrants come to the country
they work for cash under the table
they don't pay taxes they're often
exploited it's a terrible deal
why are so many people coming she said
that the trump policies were ineffective
so let me ask her this she's not going
to answer do you consider your policies
effective
how do you account for the surge in
illegal crossings
on your watch let me tell you what's
happened word is out
that the trump policies are being
replaced by the biden administration
that if you get one foot in america
you're never going to leave and people
are coming by the thousands
they'll be coming by the hundreds of
thousands by the summer
it's a humanitarian crisis it's going to
be an economic crisis for our cities
along the border
and eventually it's going to be a
national security crisis
cost their children today but they could
easily be terrorists tomorrow
this is the 20th anniversary of 9 11.
al qaeda and isis would do not would
love nothing more than to hit us again
on the 20th anniversary to show that
they're still alive and well and this
border in security is a great way for
terrorists to come into our country
just to blend in with this group let me
tell you that is a chilling
scenario senator that what you just
described
i do believe if you're right and these
new numbers are now
astronomical these are numbers we've
never seen before and i still want to
get inside the cargo shipping containers
remember
biden obama built the kids in cages
cages they built them
um i want we're putting kids in in cargo
containers
and we're told we can't videotape it and
we're told that there are butterflies on
the walls
so don't worry about it you buy that
well that's coming well that's what well
that's right it'd be all over the front
page of new york times every day
horrible conditions concentration
camp-like conditions whereas aoc by the
way
you remember kamala harris protested
outside a homestead
facility that uh when when trump used it
in homestead florida
to put children in it well that place is
now open in full
where is she all i can say is that
there's a lot of danger coming from
this wave of illegal immigration and the
numbers are going to double
uh by the summer if we don't go back to
trump policies
as embarrassing and as painfully as
painful it would be for buying an
administration
they need to understand that what trump
did on the border worked
how do you like this because i know you
said it last week
herschel walker for senate from georgia
how do you like that how does that
i like the ring of that what do you
think i
i think it's a touchdown
no football analogies all right thanks
senator appreciate it